mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
this problem is famous because a version
of it appeared on the putnam competition
and the jee advanced
these are two of the toughest exams in
the world
what is the integral from 0 to 1 of x to
the power 4 multiplied by the quantity 1
minus x raised to the power of 4
all over 1 plus x squared
use the result to prove that pi is less
than 22 over seven
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
to solve this problem we will focus on
the integrand in particular we'll
simplify the numerator
we can expand the binomial by using the
binomial theorem
we then multiply each term by x to the
power of four
we'll distribute through and then we
will simplify term by term
we then want to divide this entire
quantity by one plus x squared
we can simplify this using polynomial
long division
this is a little bit of a tedious
calculation but we'll go through it step
by step
we'll first rewrite 1 plus x squared as
x squared plus 1.
we want to eliminate the leading term to
do that we'll multiply x squared plus
one by x to the power of six
we get the following result which we'll
subtract
we'll go ahead and do this calculation
we then want to bring down the next
column
we then continue this process we will
eliminate the first term
subtract and then bring down the next
column as appropriate so the next term
will be negative four x to the power of
five
we get the following result which we'll
subtract
then we will bring down the next column
now we've run out of room so let me just
take this result to the top
we then want to eliminate the leading
term
so we multiply through and we get this
result
we'll subtract out
we then get the next term which is
negative 4x squared
we again do this calculation and we want
to continue one more time
we then have plus 4 so we eliminate this
leading term and we're left with a
remainder of negative 4.
so this negative 4 will be divided by x
squared plus one
so this is the result of polynomial long
division
so we've shown that the integrand is
exactly equal to the following result
we can thus compute our original
integral by taking the integral of the
following expression which will be much
easier to compute
we will calculate the antiderivative of
each term
so this is fairly straightforward for x
to the power of six we get x to the
power of seven over seven
then we subtract four over six
multiplied by x to the power of six
then we have plus x to the power of five
minus four over three multiplied by x to
the power of 3
plus 4x
the final one will be a little bit
tricky it's equal to negative 4
multiplied by the arc tangent of x
from here we want to evaluate this from
0 to 1.
so we can evaluate each of these at one
it'll be a fraction for each of these
polynomial terms
for the trigonometric function the
arctangent the inverse tangent of one is
equal to pi over 4 so we'll evaluate
that
we also evaluate each of these at 0 and
notice that each of these terms will
vanish
so we're going to just eliminate this
entirely
we now need to simplify this
we'll take a look at the rational terms
we end up simplifying this to be 3 plus
1 over 7 and that's equal to 22 over 7.
we then want to simplify the following
term and it will be equal to negative pi
thus we have shown that the original
integral is equal to 22 over 7 minus pi
that's part 1 of the question
next we'll consider x in the interval 0
to 1.
notice that x to the power of 4 is
positive in this interval
and the same goes for 1 minus x raised
to the power 4 and 1 plus x squared
therefore the integrand will be a
positive term it'll be greater than zero
so when we take the integral from zero
to one of a function that's strictly
positive we will get a strictly positive
result
so we have shown that 22 over 7 minus pi
is strictly positive which means that 22
over 7 is greater than pi
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you